this video is sponsored by valentine's
whiskey which means we will hear more
from them soon
first came back playing among us in like
i don't know a lifetime started as
cremate everything's great i don't
remember how to play okay okay hang on
hang on we start up here we have
one imposter
and
hey we're gonna be fine we're gonna be
fine i'm gonna be crewmate the whole
time it's gonna be great what could go
wrong
okay and i started on the map that i'm
the most familiar with because i haven't
played this game in so long
um and i've done a couple of these girls
only streams because they are super fun
feeling very alone right now electrical
has a lot of stuff in it so maybe
i will be safe
okay
this seems all right
please don't kill me dom please don't
kill me dog
she didn't she could have and she didn't
feeling good about i'll call her bambi
for audience purposes feeling good about
bambi
feeling like she is probably not a
murderer or i would have died
okay
okay
clara hello my friend clara my good
friend clara who works at devolver
digital
you would you wouldn't murder me would
you there are two of you here this is
good
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and ten
i can count
okay
i'm not seeing any dead bodies yet no
oh
that's a new animation yeah they really
updated it
if you've got a
iphone or something somebody's dead
yeah i
okay this is weird because i just walked
by
bambi's body
like i she was alive and then i came
back in a split second and she was dead
wow
[Music]
next to you it's to the right of the
cafeteria i forget because it's been so
long
so that means it was not collateral i
can tell you she was right next
somewhere okay did you was there anyone
that you saw like before
it was literally just bambi like no one
was in that room so i think someone must
have someone invented
because it was just bambi standing there
and then i came back and
she was cut in half
it was pretty sad that is super sad
but you're not allowed to speak tom
you're you're a ghost
[Laughter]
also i love that we're all level one
except for clara who played this game
for the first time yesterday
you look like an mvp
level 9.
i feel like i've installed this game
like 12 times on different computers
yeah do we want to vote because we have
39 seconds and
no one okay so no it's not it was not
collateral
her and i were in a room together that's
not me i did recently see
clara
and
lyanna but i don't know what they were
doing
i was doing that stupid task where you
have to do the memory thing and i can't
get it because i can't remember anything
i could see a clump in there around them
there's not enough information so no i'm
skipping vote
all right
all right back to tasking
um i don't know
are we i don't know it's fine it counts
we skipped it
you get to see who voted for stuff oh
interesting wait
did we not all scared
okay yeah okay yeah all right good day
i think that stella did the thing that i
used to consider to be a red flag just
now which is um
if somebody says so should we vote
what if she murdered family
what if she is the murderer
then i would be in trouble did i not do
that [ __ ] get out of here
it seems done to me there weren't any
leaves left
okay
red
blue
yellow pink
not you steph not you
i forgot how nervous this game makes me
is anybody dead
not that i have seen
we might actually oh
okay
clara
no
wait a minute i
i was ju hold on i was just i can't
remember the name of who was there i was
just there um
where
where is she where did you find that was
the body where the o2 was it's where the
o2 was
um
on the left or the right
it was the one on the right
i was at 02 with someone because i did
the task well complex the thing
collateral reported it did you also
murder
do you have news for us collateral
da2 was good was just sauntering away
from a body
oh
the whole just finally turned all the
way
[Music]
that's us dude i was on the left side
the whole time because i couldn't get
that memory thing and then i finally was
going to electrical
the problem is you're the only person
with a number in your name so it's not
like i could have confused the letters
that is true but i was not on the left
wait no left no wait was i
it was on the left side to get your left
and right wrong
[Laughter]
you was good is that you
i yeah
yeah i was the 82 i did i had to finish
up the memory thing and then i was going
down to electrical that's the only place
i went
i cannot remember whose name it was but
i just saw them with clara oh my god i'm
so mad
it was a longer name that's all i know
that is the longest name i am
literally the longest name
but like
yes but i was there completing the task
because we were running out of oxygen
which i did and i don't know
i also did that too so i just cannot
remember who are we skipping or are we
voting it's up to you it's up to you oh
i hope we're right
but okay
oh i hope we're right oh no
[Music]
oh it seems bad it seems bad the vibes
seem bad no
damn it
oh that's not good
that is not good her defense was really
bad
i'm worried about stella i'm worried
about stella and a little bit worried
about steph get away from me steph
[ __ ] are there only like four of us left
alive
bad vibes bad vibes
look at that
piece of candy one more i have to go to
med bay med bay is where people go to
die
med bay is where people get murdered
not today [ __ ]
[Music]
i think that's all my tasks done
i don't feel like collateral would just
throw somebody under a bus for funsies
oh
now everybody is scary i'm just gonna
sit right here and if somebody runs too
close i'm
just gonna play it
i mean press it
also the person who's doing it has only
done
one of the like emerge oh okay
okay
oh no
no
[Music]
stella oh it's one of the two of you and
i'm scared
oh okay i have i have a choice to make
i know it's not alana this sounds like
deflection
what do you mean as if it's not her
because earlier in the we were in the
same room when a body was found dead
you're right
but steph was just in the same room as
me right now
yeah
but she may be in the same room as me in
order to murder me so
no i thought i was i was
watching you feeling like you came and
stood next to me and were like giving me
such eyes okay where was the body found
it's definitely steph i wasn't even
standing near a
uh it was you were you were in the
cafeteria yeah but i was just chilling
there in front of the emergency button
in case somebody came to murder me
because all my tasks are done
right okay i didn't come up next to you
sitting next to me but you were watching
me like i'm certainly waiting for your
moment
to be murdered yes yes correct
no
i've done it in steph get up i hope i
really hope this is right i went so hard
that if
i'm wrong it's very nerve-wracking
i think i think it's deaf
but i'm just a lonely viking
that's pretty motorist yeah
okay
[Music]
i should have trusted my gut how did
lyanna get done so dirty
oh man i told y'all i was bad at this
game though
and i'm very rarely ever
it's so hard
[Laughter]
a smaller number of players and you're
just one imposter yeah because when
there's two of you working on opposite
sides it's easier to kind of be like oh
it wasn't me should i add one yeah
no because then i think it's probably
gonna be unbalanced
um is there anything i can do to make it
slightly easier for you like like try to
i mean i could lower kill cooldown
or
well let's try an extra imposter and
then if it feels unbalanced we'll go
back
i received a package from my good friend
moxie apparently she got hired by
valentine's scotch whiskey as the
company's chief galactic expansion
officer follow moxie on twitter or on
linkedin if you want more information
congratulations for the new job sweet
lady okay let's open this up shelley
we have a letter and this qr code here
if anyone would like to use it will give
you exclusive borderlands 3 heads oh we
also have
this very cool bar menu how neat she put
together a nice selection of drink
options for us thank you moxie and the
whiskey itself valentine's finest
moxie's bar edition blended scotch
whiskey product of scotland i think this
is going to go down very well for my
among us gameplay take a little sip of
some fine
scotch whiskey
while i play through some games
it has a really nice smell i can't wait
to try it
they did also send over
this is cool this like really cool neon
bar like light up
display
that's going to be neat so it has this
base and also
like batteries and tables and a full uh
like rgb controller how awesome so a
very big thank you to my friend moxie
for sending over this legendary loot box
including the newly launched limited
edition valentine's scotch whiskey make
sure you check out maxi's special
responsible drinking message live from
moxie's bar look out for some familiar
faces and i also wanted to let you know
that moxie is recruiting moxie's finest
a squad of borderlands streamers if you
love streaming borderlands and you
should join head to the website where
you can sign up and download her
streamer pack for exclusive content
come on
every time i'm like thank god
do your tasks i love doing tasks i love
doing detective work that's me
okay
all right that was fast
five five zero four two done
boom
all right that was quick handled that
tidy work
stella
i thought that maybe she had murdered
somebody down here and was trying to get
me out
there's nothing in there tell me it's
done thank you
go to admin
do the o2 you'd be really silly to kill
me right now right oh no hang on hang on
two zero one two two done
all right
and i'm just gonna do this and assume
somebody else is going oxygen
good
makes me think pagan is probably clear
okay
so uh clara what what what are you doing
hovering over that body
no okay
how do you report
uh
what
[Laughter]
you were still in there and you were
standing over a dead body but then who
was the person that walked out
i don't know but you might have killed
them after they
like after they walked out
i'm not good at this game okay i'm
trying to be all sleuthy
because i played it for the first time
yesterday night just so everyone is
clear that is true
where i was where was the body
level four the body isn't o2
it was i
i was really i was originally on the
right side and i went to go do my
navigation task but claire the only
reason i'm saying you this early is
because you followed me in there but
then you were standing up against the
wall and not doing anything and there
was no risk there
and then you kept following me from room
room and then i saw you hovering around
pagan in the kitchen and then when i was
in the cafeteria that i was standing
there like waiting to see what you'd do
and then you like turned around and then
just walked off
and then
i felt very intimidated okay
i'm an extremely intimidating person i
don't blame you but i was doing this
little shoot thing and then when the uh
the sabotage happened i went to do that
i was actually with somebody else doing
it
who who are you with
i actually i'm gonna vote clara i'm
gonna write clara too i will say it's
too early that it could be circumstance
but i i yeah
and the other thing the other thing too
is that um i would say lyanna i saw you
do the o2 task when i was in um admin
and like pretty sweet thing and you and
you could have killed me as well um in
that room and you didn't sway
the judgment
[Music]
she keeps getting kicked out so early
which always makes me feel bad um okay
i don't think it's steph
i don't really know like i have i don't
feel like i've seen anything suspicious
everyone seems fine
did i lose audio
um
no that's done okay cool
where did she just go she has to event
it right
stella has to have just vented she has
to have she has to i'm gonna go report
that
was it stella
i'm pretty sure it was
i didn't get a single test okay hello
i was so paranoid i didn't even get a
single test done pretty much positive
that i just saw stella in a room and
then i left it and then when i went back
to it she was gone but she wasn't in the
hallway which means she has to
eventually
she just came out
what room what room what room she just
came out of electrical until i came out
of electrical well she was in 02 a
second beforehand and i'm i'm not
actually positive it was her but i'm
pretty sure
i was literally just passing still like
our bodies were like past each other as
as their meeting was called and that was
down in the bottom hallway okay yeah
i think you may have vented from o2 to
electrical
oh my god no i literally just fixed
lights
i could again could be wrong but i'm
pretty sure that uh you were one place
and then suddenly you weren't anymore
damn that's good sleuthing though that
is good
okay but two people did see me at the
bottom so like that because you rented
them
that doesn't mean anything you can fix
lights and still be the bad guy what
other tasks have you done what other
toss did you do recently
i had
doors were closed they're like the door
to security and the door to electrical
door
yes i think she vented out when the
doors were closed
yeah i feel like
i might be wrong i'm not confident
ah i'm gonna do it imagine but it felt
like enough for me to
i'm gonna feel so bad oh no and then we
just like
actually i may have literally just seen
something completely wrong
this could be me projecting but when she
was running down the hallway she did
seem guilty
it was a very
guilty run
i literally i'm not at all confident i'm
sorry
that was wrong
oh my gosh this is the most no
this is the most nervous countdown of
all time
but if it if this was the second one
like hell a good job to all of us
because like yes
did you vent stellar
i've been accused of being an imposter
and i and i was but you didn't do the
same thing something that i didn't do
and it feels like a it feels like an
unfair defense it may have been lyanna
that i saw and then disappeared but i
don't oh well we'll take it i don't
i want to say i didn't i didn't kill
that first body i literally saw this
yeah
i killed the body and then in real life
i went what and
i didn't know how to report it
oh no
but i was also the imposter
that whole round was just an accident
really glad that was right because i
felt so guilty i was like watch claire
was innocent and i just like roasted her
and i'm gonna feel so bad and now she's
gonna hate me and this is
i
was like oh i wish i could watch a
replay because i don't know what i saw i
was like what was i looking at did i see
you just disappear from a hallway god
damn it oh that's really funny we won
but i i don't feel like we deserved it
no it was not it was intuition it's a
sleuthing don't worry about it yeah sure
[Laughter]
i think that would actually be helpful
yeah changing color okay blue okay
beautiful all right i'm gonna change my
hat i hit i hit start already
oh [ __ ] next time next time i apologize
so upset you pinks were up to something
i knew it
okay
complete accident don't know how i
managed that complete accident
oops
okay let's roll
we do a o2
well the camera just like did something
weird
okay
that was unsharp eyed i didn't see
anything nothing even happened
[Music]
all right clara okay
what's going on here clara
clara
clara
clara clara please don't kill me
please
please my best friend clara please no
please no murder why is she following me
please
do not do crimes oh okay
i thought pagan was dead she is standing
right over a vent
which is a bit weird
that was quick
always an election
i don't know
clara why were you following me
i wanted to see if you were sassy bacca
and you weren't okay great
that's bad i can't repeat that
yeah
pagan what task were you just doing
it's event task so you open the vent and
you have to clean it out it's like
dusting there are pizza slices and a
little egg
okay okay i was like why would she just
stand in every event but good to know
yeah honestly when i saw you there was
like she's gonna think i'm imposter i'm
cleaning eventually it's just being here
it's a good answer okay so i for sure
think alana is cleared because i watched
her do the little venting yeah it was
sell super weird
i was followed i also think um i was
standing next to um bambi at some point
so i don't think they were anywhere near
down the side of the map
no i was not
yeah i don't know i was in captivity so
i have no idea and then i went into
admin
i was in bottom left reaction yeah so i
don't know i didn't go down that far
there's two murderers here
yeah
it's it's always
i do we don't have enough information
though yeah we can't vote on seven i
agree i'm not sure yeah okay yeah
werewolf math i'm nervous
stay alive everybody good luck out there
[Music]
oh no
wow
oh no man no clara
i feel like we do not have enough tasks
completed for there to be this many
people dead i'm scared
actually
uh
so it was
kalathra where was the body
um it is where you do the the leaf tasks
and the i don't know where that is oh
the o2 oh okay i forget what all of the
rooms are called it's been a really long
time since no no no i totally haven't
yet so it's that hallway
um and i did see a little white bean
go down before me so
steph uh
yes that's me i'm a little white bean
only white bean and yeah i saw steph go
before me did not report which would be
weird well i didn't know i didn't see a
body there was no one dead at that point
wait at the people was like at that
point how do you know at that point
great question well i don't know i did
because i didn't see a body there was no
body throwing why did i say at that
point
because
if you found a body it would have been
after i was there
i went right for it
anywhere i am just stating myself
i went right for
we have to vote out there's two
murderers right now and the tasks are
looking bad i don't know but if you're
but if you're voting out innocent people
then you're making the situation worse i
would rather die
quickly than slowly
this is the hill she's going to die on
everybody
the excuse was weird stuff that's you
you know
right okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i feel bad every time but also you
probably murdered somebody just now so
yeah well
oh no
i feel sorry for your oh no souls oh no
space dolls oh oh no
we may have done a bad maybe a bad
happened
but again my logic is like
if we're a little at all suspicious at
this point i feel like we just have to
go for it we just gotta
we just gotta matter somebody but she
really made it seem like [ __ ]
her argument was bad
[ __ ]
stupid goddamn stupid [ __ ]
bro gamer
maybe this game didn't have achievements
last time i played because i keep
getting them
bad base game i keep like not seeing
anybody as
well stella is cool
okay
oh my one by one
ah
they all fall down um
i just came across her body just outside
the electrical on like in that little
card or outside the
door
i can't actually help from the situation
i have no idea i was on the left side
that i would be shocked if it was stella
because we just went like up and around
at the same time yeah
just came from the cafeteria direction i
did i came from med bay and then
came past you
um
bambi what are you what are you been up
to my friend i would like to i would
like to know
i mean not much
you've been killing people
like what are you i mean
no
what do you what's the last task you did
um the the the one with the beeps
yes
this is [ __ ] hilarious
yeah i said like yeah
yeah yep
i also would like to vouch for stella
stella's had pretty much every single
task that i've had
yeah we've gone to every wire box and
everything so but i was like no she's
she's just yeah
i don't know
it's almost every single task i have
stella so i would
i'm actually going to put me on this
or lana if she's playing just a really
big galaxy
she could be just doing tasks just doing
tasks out here
just your tuscaloo
i think that was right i don't know
about steph
that was amazing
that was so bad
[Music]
i refuse to get rid of the dog even
though it like incriminates me it does
it wasn't the dog i didn't do it
incriminated you though it was the way
you said it at that time yeah
yeah yeah
amazing pretty guilty sounding voice no
i actually was like oh she's you know
she started the conversation she seemed
so confident and it was only the well it
must have been after i left it made me
go well exactly
i was like how do i explain that sounded
honest though that sounded honest and
normal in when i when i said it sounds
guilty to me but then you all reacted so
strongly i was like guess i was wrong
after that
i'm like what time
yeah when did it happen it was at that
point like you had to be really
aggressive with it because yeah
eventually it's like the task
[Applause]
okay okay am i gonna tweet this whole
thing without ever being gosh dang clara
that was too quick clara that was too
quick thank you sierra
clara
clara
clara
calm the [ __ ] on
again i inherently trust stella
for no reason it doesn't make any sense
just because i generally dress up it
doesn't make sense
there isn't a lot of logic to it but
here i am
okay
a murderer yeah
already
two
sarah as well
wait
no
i wanna say it's
[Laughter]
where the lights are oh what a surprise
i will say that as i was going near that
direction i saw pagan and i don't think
it would have been possible for her to
kill that person
the way she was coming so i would be
comfortable vouching for her
um i did no tasks because every person i
ran into um i got immediately suspicious
panicked and then run the opposite
direction so i have not done anything
except absent
[Music]
so wait wait sorry which body was fine
stella was found not clara
i'm reporting stella yeah in electrical
i don't know where it is anyone have you
seen clara
no
the last time i saw clara she was
leaving admin
yeah [ __ ]
i think
this is not good it's not a good start
total task completed is very low and
multiple people have died
i feel like though oh my gosh i don't
know if i'm gonna like
well i don't want to mess something here
but lyanna like you said that you'd run
into people and then run the opposite
direction whereas if you're like that is
wholeheartedly not true for me you were
coming after me for a good bit and i was
like oh my gosh you're chasing me
so like i'm going the wrong door i felt
like i was trying to go the wrong
direction but yeah i
you followed me for a while and i was
like that's
dude
don't you have tasks buddy
you know i tried to do them i tried to
do it like an admin but then when i left
and i was trying to go see what it
leaves
i don't know where like anything is and
i went i did go down up and down the
left to see if there were any tasks
there twice
because i got confused [ __ ] i don't want
i don't feel about good about my task
but i'm going to i don't [ __ ] i'm scared
i don't have enough evidence i'm
concerned
one vote fully oh that makes sense
damn
one of you [ __ ] is you kill you
killing people out here
[ __ ]
i don't feel good about it i don't feel
good about it i don't feel good about it
i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared
we go oh hang on let me go to o2 and we
got nothing
who reported it
pagan
i think it may have been pagan
there's no way we do this on tasks
the it can't be done
i really don't know
these two seem like they're doing tasks
but
who knows
i thought there were three people in the
room
it was steph
and she vented
oh no this is bad for alana
bad news for
alana no
[ __ ]
oh i just i i wanted to not assume steph
based on the fact that she has been
imposter an unfortunate amount of times
and i got cremate every time maybe yeah
damn
so
steph is one
i don't know about the other one oh i
have to pull myself another drink
oh i pee
no
i just saw elana no he didn't i want
i have a person i suspect
i think i've seen i think i've seen this
person vent twice what but i was just
out of the program field
liana um so take it with a grain of salt
because it was out of profile so they
could have very easily been doing like
the cleaning the vince task but i want
to say i saw stefan
you probably didn't you did you better
be in the navigation room with someone i
want to say hey
it's me yeah myself and stuff are in
navigation yeah okay
i've been alone a few times
after she murdered me
is the other one pagan are you assuming
yeah
yep
collateral i think it's clear as well so
i'm i'm kind of thinking that it's bumby
and lyanna
so i just think i
okay i'm gonna call a play here thank
you creepy person i'm gonna go ahead and
say i think it's pagan and stuff because
pagan you don't that's what i'm saying
defend people that hearty unless you're
the imposter and your voice gets a lot
deeper when you feel aggressive
i feel like you've called me out my
accent before lyanna and i think that
i'll be close to you was i right though
she was right that time you were the
imposter that type too
no
pagan and i literally were just in the
same room together so we can vouch for
each other but same with kalathra i've
been with camasha with this whole round
as well i actually don't think
i don't feel like pagan sounds like
she's lying to me
oh cause yeah i feel like people have
done that but i'm gonna vote steph
because pagan that is just like i don't
know you well enough but i'm pretty sure
i saw stuff but i feel like i'm going
she said twice because why would you do
that if i trust pagan and pagan trusts
kalathra
why
why did i'm skipping
rest in peace me
what
oh my god
i keep expecting
we're going to be able to find out if
the person i'm so used to knowing
her or not answer
oh my god
watching you all go for bambi for no
reason
baby didn't do anything big fairy they
never and i
somebody brought her name up and i just
had to latch onto something i'm so sorry
she didn't do anything
absolutely
i was like well like you're out how'd
she go i was sorry i was just doing my
job oh my god that was savage i'm sorry
for suspecting you lyanna apologize yeah
that was great yeah i'm sorry i'm so
sorry i played so hard by steph i was
marinated
you were marinated not bad at it that
was good
it was so funny as well i was talking to
chat and i was like i feel like i need
to talk less because as the game is is
progressing people are starting to hear
my and discover my tells
yeah
and it was so true i was like the more i
talk the more they're starting to get to
know me and realize that i'm actually
not a good liar